so the latest update i have as of this
moment
and to not talk about it would be weird
but i have to acknowledge that
things are moving very quickly and we
may have different news by the time you
listen to today's show is
the news is that donald trump may be
going home
soon today he may already be home or
maybe not he still is
scheduled to have a rally tonight which
i mean just completely inconceivable
obviously if he did it it would be
some kind of remote thing he would be
joining via remote video donald trump of
course
is not traveling uh to a rally tonight
but he's either doing well or not doing
well we just don't know we are left to
try to infer and to try to wade through
the lies but one thing we have in black
and white is that this morning donald
trump sent 20 20 consecutive completely
manic tweets in a very short period of
time from the hospital
almost all in capital letters and once
again this could be anything
is trump tweeting because he's panicked
that the latest polls are really bad
is he simply manic from the
dexamethasone
corticosteroid-induced mania is not an
uncommon side effect
of dexamethasone and other steroids we
just don't know
but the tweets are completely outrageous
take a look at just
some of these as you can see here donald
trump tweeting
most of these are all caps stock market
highs
vote virginia voters your governor wants
to obliterate your second amendment
i have stopped him if you want a massive
tax increase the biggest in the history
of our country and one that will shut
our economy and jobs down vote democrat
i'm voting for donald trump my father is
a union worker and his 401k
has tripled under president trump uh
obviously
the stock market hasn't tripled so if
the 401k has tripled maybe the person
started contributing three times as much
sort of a non-sequitur
then just another string of all caps
tweets pro-life
vote massive regulation cuts vote space
force
vote best va ever 91
approval rating vote 401 k
vote biggest tax cut ever and another
one coming
vote religious liberty boat law and
order
vote peace through strength vote save
our second amendment
vote fight the corrupt fake news media
vote
protect pre-existing conditions vote
better and cheaper health care vote
so um completely out of control
uh could this be a combination
of a steroided up trump seeing the
latest nbc
poll which has them down by 14 points to
joe biden
and simply doing what he feels he can do
from a hospital our friend
farron cousins from ring of fire wrote
to me on twitter
most likely it's the steroids i've been
on them before for severe asthma
and they can make you very angry and
aggressive has someone
again lost control of trump it is
all speculation brought on by the
reality that trump's behavior doesn't
make any sense
and his doctors aren't being honest and
this administration hasn't been honest
about trump's health since day one
and trump lies about everything
dexamethasone rare side effect of the
drug
includes grandiose delusions
how would you be able to tell the
difference with this guy and some
experts have expressed concern
about the combinations of things trump
has gotten as you now know
trump received an unapproved antibody
cocktail
redesever and dexamethazone
at minimum that we know of dr thomas
mcginn
from the new york state health provider
northwell
health said to the new york times that
the kitchen
sink is being thrown at donald trump and
dr
vin gupta said you don't start
dexamethasone
redesevere and an antibody treatment
that is yet unapproved
if the president just slightly has a
lower oxygen
level you do it when there's covered
pneumonia or something more serious
will we ever know the truth i really
don't know we certainly don't know it
right now
and we've certainly never gotten the
truth on a whole bunch of other things
that have happened during the last four
years so we may never know
next we are going to talk about more
overt
doctoring of the tapes as the case may
be
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's
solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get 20 off your entire order when
you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video